gentlemen ladies what if Superman had  decided to fly down rip off the roof of  the White House  grab the president right out of the Oval  Office remembering everything doesn't  mean you know everything would have  stopped  I want to build a team of some very bad  people who I think can do some good  Jesus Christ that's Jason Bourne  you're never gonna find any please not  till you admit to yourself who you  really are  no my mother used to call me  dangerous  and dangerous  with you until I died validations  I'm not the girl I used to be  we should be better  speaker adjusted  but we'll take revenge you are  humanity's final  these same things  he knows things  be wall safer because of what you Ted